hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca on foreign again today we got a
little bit of info to talk about today
nothing too crazy but we're gonna get a
lot more later in the next couple weeks
with the Vorta girl reveal and the live
stream as well so it's always like the
beef we do enjoy a subscriber for new I
cover the informational side of foreign
that being bounced changes hero updates
patch notes and leaks we want to get
kept up-to-date with all the info on for
honor and what's happening within the
game this guide to my channel and with
that let's get started so first up guys
welcome back felt like I was going
through withdrawal there I haven't done
a warrior's den video in like three
weeks I was getting cravings and [ __ ]
like that but we're back now so first
thing I want to cover since it's gonna
be one of the longer things of the video
is the content of the week we finally
have content now this week and the
content is going to be new ornaments 22
new ornaments for every single hero and
they're all different so that's really
nice to see they all seem to have a
skull and bat type theme the video GUI
on screen now if you want to see those
spicy ornaments they're gonna be costing
5,000 steal the video will be sped up a
bit since this is like a two and a half
to three minute video and I don't want
just taking up like half of it so
apologies for that
first up the 31st is the release date of
the new vertigo hero and season now they
didn't actually specify if this is the
name of the hero or just the season they
never actually said and they're not
going to tell us they're gonna keep it
hush-hush for a couple weeks so right
now I'm just gonna call him bored agar
just to make this a little easier but
yeah that's gonna be the new hero like I
said there's gonna be a reveal stream on
the 24th a week before this comes out so
if you do have the season passed you'll
be able to play them on the 31st and if
you do not have the season pass you will
be able to play this character a week
after sometime in February I'm thinking
February 7th or 8th should be the
correct date for that on top of that
there's also a year 3 past this is gonna
be including a champion status a
scavenger crate in the new effect which
would be on which was shown on screen
right now I don't know if the ornaments
are still going right now as I'm talking
but if they are it'll be shown after
those it's gonna be called be
thunderbolt and frightening and the Year
3 pass has been available for quite some
time so you may have already gotten it
but just in case you haven't that's what
is included like I said it is the effect
champion status and scavenger crates the
past is gonna be about $30 if you live
in the US and I believe
the Canadian so I'm not entirely sure
what the other countries have in terms
of conversion currency but for the US
and Canada it's gonna be 30 for us 40
for Canadians solstice is the new our
cave quest if you want to play that I
don't believe it's anything special
probably your standard our cave quest if
you didn't get the Creed stuff that you
wanted from the for the Creed event you
can buy the for the create event bundle
in the store right now that'll be
available for the next couple days so
get that before it leaves and then
lastly on screen now I have a couple
t-shirt designs that were shown for an
art contest or it's actually a t-shirt
contest happening within for honor right
now I'd say that the devs or the
community picket I do believe it's the
developers and whatever one they like
the most actually gets put on a t-shirt
you could wear and actually buy from the
Ubisoft store I couldn't show all of
them because there were so many but I
wanted to show these to these were
definitely two of my favorites so let me
know your thoughts on these two designs
I think this is a great huge artistic
ability all I can draw a stick figures
so this is easily better than my
drawings I know I said the t-shirt was
gonna be the last thing but I was
actually watching the end of the stream
and I just wanted to actually say the
last part is a big thank you to Damian
he's one of the developers and one of
the guys on the Warriors then every
single week he's gonna be leaving the
team I believe he's going to the
location in France I still believe he's
gonna be with Ubisoft you might still be
with the game I'm not entirely sure I
didn't get to hear everything but he
will not be on the Warriors then anymore
so big thank you to Damian EPS in the
chat for him it was a lot of fun he was
reading jokes at the end of the stream
this is a picture if you guys haven't
seen him already
way he's a very helpful guy during the
Warriors that much well say thank you to
him real quick just the case if he's
watching this Thank You Damian hey guys
that's officially the end of the video
today hope you guys do enjoy like the VP
do enjoy subscribe for new I've covered
the informational site or foreigner that
being balanced changes hero updates
patch notes leaks all that good stuff if
you want to be kept today with
everything in for honor and stay tuned
to the channel but that my two most easy
videos will be on screen if you guys
want to check that out that guys have
ever greater day I think Forks in the
video enjoy the rest of your day peace
out
[Music]
you